hi i'm kaliuchis artist singer
songwriter hi i'm maya murillo from
better like and we're here with tasty to
beat the pro hayaka version two of the
internet's finest face off against a
professional chef assembling or building
a food item of the chef's choosing
today's subject is ayakas maya and i
have five minutes to build more ayakas
than a professional chef so i'm
mexican-american so i've i have tamales
like every holiday season so these are
like with banana leaves and like the
masa is different i don't know i'm up
for the challenge so i think we can do
it also we have nails on clearly write a
disadvantage but also if we do this
right then it's like is he really a chef
i wasn't gonna mention this because i
try to be humble but i actually taught
him everything he knows i freaking knew
it if he beats us i would just be happy
for him you know like the student
teaching the teacher let's meet him come
on come on come on down bud hi how are
you
nice to meet you
jorge nice to meet you i'm jorge rincon
i've been a chef for 20 plus years
ajakas are my specialty alliance is our
biggest tradition in venezuela is like a
tamales but there's a lot of more stuff
inside and there's a lot of more work
inside also so it's a family and
national dish wrapping a jackass is
difficult usually somebody at the family
is the expert i'm not sure if kali and
maya they're going to make it this is
going to be a challenge for you i guess
it's not easy you have to pay attention
and hopefully you are good with your
hands the steps of making the jackass
are first you have to have a really nice
plantain leaf put the masa on top and
you're gonna press it and put the pork
and all the decoration on top then is
the time to close it again you're gonna
fold it with another banana leaf cali
and maya they won't press the masa and
they're just going to wrap it in only
one leaf do you really think you're
going to beat me yeah that's out of my
mind are you ready for that i'm ready
i'm doing this from long time ago we
just did it right now so
a little bit more no chicken no chicken
try to close it you do this oh you look
like you kind of got it i know kelly
what the hell it's perfect let's do this
three
two
one go
don't put oliver i'm gonna sue you
kelly it's me so at the beginning of the
day i've only had like one ayaka in my
life so i was a little intimidated this
isn't fun
okay yeah i made tamales before so i i
kind of figured it was going to be the
same he's not doing anything important
over there i don't worry about the
competition kelly i'm not i'm not
checking on you jorge don't check on
this i'm so so behind i'm not checking
for you okay mine ripped don't tell him
when bad things happen you gotta make
sure you have to keep the shape oh my
god he's right he's already done one i
was focused on mine i was just checking
her attackers and they were they were
okay this is the way it should be let me
show you okay you were tampering with
this before because it's ripping already
i almost done boom no i'm almost done
too i'm almost done with your business
in your business sweetie uh-oh
and you have to tie it right into the
next
there's one i can't tell this with my
nails that's one we are two one now we
got this this is we have two he has one
i'm not worried about it at all and
start having issues here i taught jorge
these things like a long time ago so you
know what kelly's so chill some people
like to acknowledge their teachers and
some people don't jorge is just not
really one of those people
no i just want
these looks pretty i wasn't so much
worried about making it look cute
because at the end of the day it's all
going to the same place yeah when you
open it have to be just like a present
it's so sweet it's a competition yeah
it's friendly and i know that i'm gonna
win anyways mind were nicer they were
perfect
boom three one kelly distracted oh right
distract them with their voice
you hear that
i gotta go sleep
if this was in quality
who's the better wrapper between the two
of you definitely me yes it's you for
sure wow
30 seconds 30 seconds okay you know what
i'm just 30 seconds for what i'm
wrapping up
no way really hear that did you hear
that in his voice oh he was so stressed
because he realized he was gonna lose
almost give me one more minute no okay
okay
i was just nervous because of the amount
of foul play that jorge engaged in like
breaking the scissors
with my scissors oh yeah i couldn't okay
i couldn't even cut my last tamales
you know what yes i'm going to cut this
last one because jorge tampered with my
so powerful i did only with my eyes
[Laughter]
we did it i love that you don't mind
losing i really love that about you
that's like one of your most adorable i
thought i could win but it seems like
you have six they are not pretty dull
but
nobody was wearing that nobody was
worried about pretty much
had to be pretty nobody was no one was
worried about pretty i try
let's count and see how many i have now
i have one is a nice one it's pretty and
two no one was worthless yeah and they
are delicious also they are delicious
inside
we have two thousand and four
they're all sealed let's see sealed
right
sealed sealed let me take a look no i
don't want to see that one it's not this
yeah well let's see this is a new
version this is a new tradition this is
this one maybe not this one's definitely
not sealed but either way it doesn't
count either way we still had more that
was clearly mayas i don't know what to
say so how many do you got
four thousand i have two thousand and a
half we made them bro
[Music]
i got beat well that happens sometimes
you know jorge tried he tried to check
the competition honestly i tried i tried
but
you won well we did it we won calories
yeah
i feel really good i feel like i can add
this on my resume i'm feeling powerful
yeah i just don't know how much maya
actually helped me so i just think it's
really funny that she's trying to
celebrate with me when i clearly was the
one who did all of those i mean listen
you were faster than me okay
but some of them girl i did not do this
one this one was you um i don't know we
would have to check back on the camera
roll roll the tape roll the tape tricky
tricky but look at this this is those
are perfect they did a good job but in
fact jackass is about also how they
taste and how good they are looking so
mine were really good looking ajakas we
beat the pro vamos a comer who eat them
now
i always knew we could do this i always
knew we had it in us it was never our
intention to end your career that was
not the intention so i just want to say
that his were prettier than ours they
were really pretty but listen like thank
you so much for taking the time to be
here with us and for letting us play
this like little game with you i
ugh i cannot wait to like taste this
please taste that and he's we love you
so much he's you guys he's so nice well
i had so much fun i'm maya from better
like i'm cali uchis and my new single
solita's out now thank you tasty for
having us and we beat the pro we love
you sorry about it buddy
bye
oh yes
[Music]
you